[Music]
Rich it is a pleasure to have you on the
show thank you for making the time
thanks for having me Tim I thought we
would begin with something that came up
in my research and that is R&J
confectionary could you please explain
for listeners what R&J confectionary was
R&J confectionary was to most people it
was a store which my dad owned and
operated you know community store sat on
the corner of 125th in Edmonton on the
east side of Cleveland in the Glenville
area for me it was Harvard
Stanford
pen that's what it was for me it was my
curriculum it was my education it was
where I was
molded and built and taught so many
different things just through
interaction and
also what I would say was just being
able to observe as well now what types
of things were you observing what age
were you and you first started spending
time there could you just paint a
picture for us yeah I was very young I
probably first started spending time in
the store when I was first able to walk
yeah right and so a lot of the customers
there watch me grow up and over time the
neighborhood obviously changed and so
there were there were great days fun
days where you you know you little kid
running around the store helping picking
out candy eating candy playing with your
friends and then there were days in
which you started to see a difference
right you started to see I started to
see my friends
moms go from this vibrant
beautiful person to you know kind of
strung out on crack I saw young men go
from playing sports to
now interacting and engaging in things
as an adult I
saw a lot of violence but at the same
time you know it was where you you got
to observe and see how people moved and
people that you looked up to or you
thought were cool and so it was just
this combustion of activity throughout
the day and my dad kind of sat as the
air traffic
control by him owning the store and
things of that nature and so I learned a
lot of what to do I learned a lot of
what not to do I had several influences
both good and bad several instances in
which I was able
to you know probably experience some
things and hear some conversations that
at that age you probably shouldn't but
at the same
time when I look back on on it I'm so
glad I was able to because it really put
a lot of things in perspective
especially for the seat I sit in
now now on the cover of your book I
believe you're around 14 13 or 14 years
old yeah that's correct and I'm curious
why you chose that photo or that age for
the cover I think that's the age where
in life there's a fork in a row right
and I think for me and it's just in my
experience that's the age in which a lot
of my
friends started off started to you know
go down a different Road and and that's
the age for us growing up where you
actually feel like you're an adult I'm
going to make this decision you're held
accountable for it the mun League
football games and the baseball games
and things like that for some are not as
exciting now I want to make money now I
want to you know stay out all night and
and just do certain things and so that
was the age when I had several pictures
to choose from but I chose that picture
because I think if you think about even
now in today's especially in in in my
community Across America where I come
from in all communities like that that
age is just so important that's the age
where you start
to go down One path or the other and I
started losing a lot of friends around
that age so let's hop to the present
tense and we're going to go back to a
lot of things that I want to ask you
about including James Baldwin who is
endlessly interesting and fascinating to
me
but I would like to ask you about
something I know very little about and
that is the free agency period so my
understanding is
that in the Frantic period that ensued
this past July you negotiated something
along the lines of close to $900 Million
worth of
contracts and I would love for you just
to give us a behind the scenes glimpse
of how you prepare for that and what
that type of process looks like once the
the clock strikes and kind of the game
is on what is that experience like for
people who don't have any familiarity
well yeah for those who who look at it
on ESPN or online it's like okay it's
midnight July 1 phone lines are open
everybody can get to work for me and for
us my team free agency doesn't start
July 1 in terms of your preparation you
start prepping beginning of the year
probably before the season summer league
there's a lot of things that you need to
prep for there's a lot of posturing
there's a lot of conversations
information just watching what other
teams do as well as development and kind
of giving your guy some insights as well
so he can position himself better and
understand what the team is looking for
or whatnot and so by the time you get to
July you pretty much have a a decent
board there could be sometimes you don't
know and there's teams pop up out of
nowhere but once that hits now you
you're taking meetings with different
teams and if you're lucky enough to have
a guy that has multiple teams then he's
trying to decide what fits best for him
and his family on one end and then
you're trying to decide a number on the
other end with that team and so it's
pretty hectic it's a lot that comes with
it I know it looks easy but it's not
easy it doesn't look easy yeah and you
were blessed to reach that number and
I'm still in negotiations right now with
a couple guys and so it never ends when
you're doing the prep and you say when
you have a decent board and again I
apologize before we start recording but
I'm coming in very uneducated okay with
with this type of thing I just don't
have the familiarity of I followed a few
few sports but mostly boxing and fight
Sports so with that in mind what does it
look like to have a decent board in
front of you in terms of what you've
decided or strategy or anything else
what does that look like when you talk
about a decent board I'm speaking about
the options that you may have based upon
the players you represent this year we
had a number of players that were sought
after by number different teams and so
when you have those options that's
incredible you know that's any any agent
will tell you that's very hard to
do and then it's just a matter of
getting things done in a timely matter
teams one thing about it if teams had
like to be able to move and so if you're
moving your feet slow they have to jump
to somebody else very few people team's
going to wait on very few people teams
going to wait on and so when you do have
somebody that teams are actually going
to wait on you also have to balance that
too because you want to be respectful to
them as well and their time right and so
I try not to stram people along at the
end of the day you have to give yourself
time but there's definitely a balance so
I'd love to get into maybe a a story or
some specifics of the negotiating
process because by all accounts you're
considered a master negotiator
and I'll give one example maybe if you
could speak to this how did information
that you received negotiating for
Draymond Green's contract which I think
was 4 years 100 million in how you then
approached the market for Jeremy Grant
which ended up being 5 years 160 million
I'm just wondering how things play
actually Jeremy was done before
draymond's Oh okay great jery was done
before draymond's but to answer your
question Draymond was in a much
different situation than Jeremy he
obviously he's older he's been on the
team one team for 11 years at the time
he's a guy that you know his stats may
not necessarily show his value but when
you plug him somewhere he brings a
tremendous value he brings a
championship experience a chip he's one
of the smartest guys on the court every
night and so when you're looking at when
you're negotiating for somebody like
Draymond analytics and all those things
don't really matter in Jeremy's case we
had already understood what was
happening in Portland and with their
star player at that time but we also
kept the conversation and communication
to understand that they valued Jeremy
there as well regardless what was going
on with their star player so that was
great to know and then there were some
other teams around the league that
anybody can use a 69 athletic Wing like
Jeremy versatile the whole nine and it
was a matter of if he wanted to stay in
Portland despite what may have taken
place and so he
did and he had other teams with cap
space that would actually spend the
money where Draymond was a little bit
different in order to get to his number
there was very few teams with the cap
space to do that so now you got to look
at a sign and trade which we had a
signning trade lined up but ultimately
Draymond wanted to stay with the
Warriors that's where he was drafted
that's where he's had success and so at
that point you just have to turn and and
make the best deal with with the team
that he was on so that's what I was able
to do so I'd like to and this may be
pushing for a tie-in but I'm
curious what type of gambling you were
referring to when you were younger right
so when you were a kid yeah we gambled
on everything if two people had
discrepancy the next word was bet that
was my mentality since I was seven eight
years old my dad taught me how to shoot
Dice and play cards and then that led to
horseshoes or betting on any sports that
you were capable of doing whether it was
racing from in to end or whether you
decided to shoot jumpers at the park at
from the top of the key like you would
see on white man can't jump we really
did that at our park and I was you know
I practiced it to the point to where I
perfected it to where I can shoot with
one hand and so allowing me to if I'm
betting a guy and I'm going to shoot
with one hand his bet has to be more
than my bet because I'm at a
disadvantage you know sort of speaking
so everything we did whether it was
pingpong whether it didn't matter what
it was shooting poo I didn't want to
play poo unless we were betting I didn't
want to Bowl unless we were betting and
so I just had that mentality growing up
that just everything was about a bet and
so that's the type of gambling that was
Street gambling prior to me playing the
Cino but I don't really gamble as much
the casino as I would in the streets
just a totally different vibe for me
what are some of the things that made
you effective in Street gambling and
were there any particular games that
were your specialty or types of bets
yeah shooting dice I was special I had a
you know like Steph Curry has a great
three-point shot I had a great shot you
know I was I was to Steph Curry of dice
shooting for
sure but there's also a confidence and
there was also a for some real weird
reason I felt like I can actually talk
to the dice and they could to me MH that
was my pet like everyone has a dog or
teddy bear like the dice was kind of my
pet I would go around and just you know
and just gamble I would gamble against
anybody it didn't matter who it was you
know I would shoot dice against my
grandmother if she had some money and
wanted to bet and that was just my that
was just my mentality so it was great it
was good though and and you know but it
was dangerous at times and I think about
it all the time sometimes like just
being behind abandoned buildings or in
the basement of an abandoned house and
you got this money and for things to go
the way they went for me I'm extremely
lucky if we come back to the free agency
period I'm I'm curious if for instance
if you were for whatever reason
sidelined and you had to coach someone
to step in in your place to have a lot
of the conversations to do a lot of the
planning that you're talking about are
there any key pieces of advice that you
might give them or Warnings that you
might give them do not do this I tried
this once it's a bad idea any advice
that you think would be key there's
several things you know you got to
really watch out for friendly fire
there's a ton of friendly fire out there
what do you mean by that friendly fire
in terms of giving too much information
to somebody and then they share that
information not knowing who they're
sharing it with right backfires on you
but you in the ass that happens a lot
you got to prepare we've seen things
happen this year with guys and and it's
not necessarily their fault they wasn't
prepared you know you you're going into
a meeting with somebody you have to know
pretty much what they're looking for
right and be able to kind of try to feel
the answers to the test
already patience can't
Panic you can't take any of it personal
it's not a personal thing and I always
say some people Define the business card
and some people are defined by their
business card and so I don't carry a
business card so I it puts things in
perspective for you but ultimately every
year I learn something new I'm a sponge
man I like to be
educated I have a different temperament
than most would probably have and at the
end of the day you're only going to be
as strong as your client if you have a
strong client they trust
you and they they are line then you know
I've been in situations where a deal got
done in one day and I've been in
situations where it took three and a
half months and I was fine with either
one how did you first meet
LeBron we met in the airport aan
airport what was the way in which you
guys met did you go up to him did he say
something to you I had a war Moon Oilers
Jersey on that that kind of caught his
attention and then he asked me about the
jersey and that's what started the
conversation and then that led to us
kind of bumping into each other again at
the baggage claim and I gave him my
business card because at the time I was
I did have a business card and I was
selling a jerseys to a store that he he
can go to locally in Atlanta and then
when he got back to Ohio they reached
out to me again and then that kind of
started the relationship how did the
relationship evolve from that point when
I was young I just again my life had
really gave me so many different tools
and experiences and so when you were a
young kid like they were I had all the
things I had the clothes I had the
jewelry I had the car I had the knoow I
had the confidence you know I had the
experience and we would just talk but I
think the thing that Drew us together
and closer was our
moms I was able to see him and observe
things and have conversations with him
where he could be himself and not feel
the need to protect himself because I
was going through the same thing or I
had gone through the same thing and so
that was really brought us closer
together the family similarity family
similarity yeah I know I'm bouncing
around a lot but that's sort of the
nature of my mind
so so I'm trying to tease out some of
the the influences or models that you've
had I know you have portraits of a
number of different
people and I understand one of those is
James Baldwin and I was wondering if you
could just
explain what this significance is of
James for you or why you're attracted to
him obviously I didn't grow up with him
in that space But just watching old
videos and things like that just what he
stood for how articulate he was how he
how he saw things and broke it down and
the way he did it I think it's it's
important to to really pay homage to
people like that that room that that
picture's in I have a number of people
from entertainers to activists to actors
from some of my favorite movies both you
know mob movies and
movies that was created by the John
Singleton and Hughes brothers and so on
so forth as well as different Legends
and music and sports so that's a room of
inspiration for me but James Balwin in
particular you know at at a time where
it wasn't popular to be as blunt as he
was it wasn't ideal for someone who
looked like him to be as smart and
articulate as he was was and not just on
the surface but in
depth that moved me and that was
somebody I felt
like I wanted to to have on my
wall yeah I encourage everybody who's
listening if you are not familiar with
the name look up James Baldwin I mean so
brilliant so as as you mentioned
articulate and also very good
at presenting the messiness of life in a
way that wasn't overindulgent but very
truthful and bold like you mentioned and
had very complicated life himself like a
lot of people but I've collected quotes
of his for the last uh year or two just
an incredible
incredible depth of character so I
encourage people to check out James
Baldwin if you haven't
already you have been incredibly
successful in a world that on some level
at least at points has prioritized or
highlighted formal degrees how has that
lens affected you well I finished high
school at a very high
level yeah I just didn't need college I
actually made an attempt to go to
college and I actually enjoyed school I
really did but my life was different and
for what I needed to do I felt like you
know I was prepared my dad did an
unbelievable job in my environment did
an unbelievable job of preparing me and
equipping me with the tools necessary
for me to persevere through life I think
Society Paints the picture of that you
need a higher education for certain
things and I think that when you go to
get a job they go by what your education
status is which again for some jobs I
understand it but most kids that
graduate college they're not working in
their field that they got a degree in
anyway so I don't know how much of a
indicator it is yeah but I always felt
prepared especially for what I do for
sure at some point and again this is
this is me just looking at some reading
in the process of preparing for this but
the NCAA announced a rule at one point
that agents could not represent College
athletes unless they themselves had a
college degree now at face value that
seems
ridiculous and then LeBron dubbed on
Twitter this particular regulation the
the hashtag the the rich Paul rule why
why do you think they tried to put this
into action and how did they justify it
also there was really no justification I
think they they tried to put it into
action to prevent the next Rich Paul
because it wasn't about as much as it
was about me it wasn't nothing they
could actually do to me right but but
they could discourage someone else and
it's no different than again you have to
have have a college degree to become
this person well if you look at it and
if you do the
data that basically carves out a
specific group of people that are going
to be given opportunity based
upon the completion of a higher
education because one thing about life
life don't always afford you to pay
attention
to higher education especially when you
grew up the way I did in terms of and I
know people had it worse than I did and
so when you talk about just trying to
survive and try trying to survive the
day the week the month you know younger
siblings and lights are off gas is off
it's a just a
different Dynamic and it's it's unfair
in a lot of ways
because you basically feel trapped a lot
of times and so I feel like again that's
just a
discouragement and that's just an excuse
to be able to say why you didn't give
somebody an opportunity because they
didn't have this right but there's I
think there's more people that can
actually learn on the job training
unless it's something like you have to
code at Microsoft or apple or you have
to and even that like you know there's
Geniuses that learn this stuff at home
they're not learning it from a textbook
right and so I just think it's all
[__] to be honest with
you yeah think seems like people came
around on it yeah whether they like to
or not end up on the same page what
would you say are any of the sort of
best investments you've made and I'll
explain what I mean because you you have
taken a very unorthodox path to get to
where you are right but you you have
studied and you've learned and observed
like like you mentioned right from a
very young age and so for for instance
I'll just give a couple examples like
Warren Buffett would say one of his best
investments maybe his best investment
was taking a public speaking course Dale
Carnegie because it sort of Amplified
everything he was able to do a lot of
people on the podcast have put time into
something or energy into something that
paid dividends
later what have been some of the best
investments of time or energy or money
that that you've put
in in terms of something that laid the
ground for something that happened later
if that makes any sense for me it was
the dry runs you know getting out on
that road driving to to get in front of
a family and coming up short I think it
really allows you to decide if this is
something you really want to do and if
so now I have to figure out ways to get
better because I didn't I didn't play
the money game you know when I got into
this business I didn't play theone money
game I didn't play the cut your fee game
I didn't do any of that all the stuff
that's still going on now MH I didn't do
that and I was up against the bigger
agencies that had the perception the
cache and they had the the
alliances Within These universities and
things like that to to help them give
them information give families the
number or give the number of families
and then sit a kid in the room and tell
them don't tell them not to go somewhere
because they don't want that on but they
will tell them why they should go here
so now when you call the coach they say
well I didn't tell them not to come with
you but you didn't tell them they should
either but you told them they should for
this company that you happen to be
represented by and stuff like that so I
had to deal with all those type of
things and navigate my way around that
which I did that was one of the best
investments for sure I think the other
thing was just kind of investing itself
knowing that and believing that despite
the shortcomings just stay at it it'll
turn and that again in the dice game we
used to have to be able to say can you
send the rain you know a guy is throwing
point after point after point and you
would have to stand in there and send
the rain and eventually they turn and
things go the other way so I was
prepared so when you mentioned you you
weren't playing the money game do you
mean that you were not cutting your fees
as a way to try to make yourself more
attractive could you say a bit more
about that yeah not cutting my fees is a
way to make your cuz every want you know
people don't believe in your work
practice or your expertise and then the
bigger companies they're able to do that
because they're just rolling it all into
their annual revenue so if you got right
the larger machine 25 different
verticals okay so Sports is one of them
and you roll it into it and then they
look at it as you know we'll we'll
charge to hire less we'll charge the
middle more and we'll charge the lower
the Max and they'll be appreciative to
be here because we probably shouldn't be
representing them anyway and then we'll
roll it all up and at the end of the day
it goes on our books and what's dead is
dead and what's you know like I I have a
clear understanding of the business and
so but when you are on your
own you don't have that you know you
can't do that and so I was able to get
players despite that and it actually
drove them crazy and still does to this
day yeah better D him crazy so what was
your what were your selling points right
because the the big agencies have all of
the stuff that we could probably guess
they would use to sell right we've got
all this coverage we've got all these
verticals we can expand in these
following ways etc etc etc what did you
find over time as you're putting in reps
and learning after coming up short and
then improving what were your main
selling points that allowed you to get
some of those key early folks I think
there was a genuine they can feel that
in the room there was an actual real
care for who they were as individuals
and as
families I just thought different from a
i lab with education I wasn't selling
anything because I found out very early
there's nothing to sale you can go in
with your PowerPoint you know back in
the day we put the CD in and
show all these other people that the
company represented but the reality was
those people were never going to touch
those people they never going to and
those people don't actually care about
the people that's in this room so you
know you're showing that as if it's all
one family and it's not right and so I
just really Shine the Light on that and
the people that gave me an
opportunity I did right by them which
got me the next opportunity
MH You' said in a GQ interview which had
a great title so rich Paul power Brer of
the year that the biggest obstacle or
one of the biggest obstacles for young
players in learning how to become a pro
or be a pro is establishing
infrastructure yes what do you mean by
infrastructure most guys that's athletes
especially they they've come from an
environment to where everyone along the
way has made it about them and so if you
have the mentality that is only about me
then you're not going to Value other
people and what their capabilities are
what their expertise is but if you a
walking Corporation we can't name one
corporation that does not have
infrastructure organization they have an
organizational chart they have people
that do certain things and there's
Clarity within that infrastructure but
it comes with the cost and so most
athletes don't want to do what they
don't want to pay anybody to do anything
because along the way everyone has did
things for them for free but it wasn't
really for free it was to be able to be
standing there next to them at a time
where there was actually something to
gain so I'll sacrifice this now when
you're an amateur to be able to stand
next to you to get some crumbs or
whatever the case when you become a pro
right and whatever their their
aspirations were if it was to hang out
to to the girls to travel whatever it is
the money whatever it was but you see
what they did basically you
created something that ultimately became
your own demise because upfront you
taught them wrong y you taught them oh
I'm doing this out of love I'mma pick
you up I'mma do this I'mma do that all
to turn it around on them when they
start making money and say remember when
I did this or I did that well that's not
fair to the player and it's also not
fair to yourself what the conversation
should be like is look I understand you
don't have the ability to pay for
anything and if you're a parent I'm
doing it out of love I love you you're
my kid but if you're somebody else just
be honest with it hey look I'm going to
do all I can to help you get to where
you need to go once you get there if
there's an opportunity for me then I'm
going to do all I can to position myself
to where if you give me that opportunity
I can then be of value to you right very
simple when free isn't free right it's
an unclear prepayment for things to come
later that's when it seems like things
can get extremely messy how do you help
them when they say sign with you or even
just start to develop relationship with
you to take the first steps for building
out infrastructure what are some of the
first steps that you might
recommend I would say checks and
balances really getting the proper
financial team in place and that's
everybody from a CPA to the guy who
manages your Investment Portfolio or to
the company that managed your Investment
Portfolio really having somebody monitor
that because that's a very fragile thing
there but at the same time deciding what
it is that you that you want I like to
live a certain way now that I understand
better on how to live right and so if
you are a single man with no family do
you really need a 20,000 foot home
not right you're not going to be home
half the time do you really need to fly
private probably
not so there's different ways to go
about it but what's most important
should you hire a chef yes you should
should you take a shortcut on that no
you shouldn't do you know the difference
between a chef and the cook you should
find that out because this is very
important your Chef should then go and
sit with your nutritionist on your team
and figure out you should do all the
testing everything you need because your
body ultimately it's the engine that
keeps you running that's how you make
your money what are some of
the key ingredients
for sort of emotional support and
stability I'm just imagining young
athletes who are suddenly in the
Limelight they have all the Temptations
they have a lot of pressure there must
be and I mean I know few professional
athletes who've gone through these
periods periods that are very
challenging and certainly after
retirement or the end of their playing
years some very challenging
times what have you seen in terms of the
best ways to support that could be from
your side it could be other ingredients
player Health on that side of the Ledger
nowadays I think there needs to be
someone that players need to talk to and
be open-minded to having a therapist to
get stuff off their chest they deal with
a lot they deal with a lot I think it's
also important for players to not feel
entitled to do
things you know often times they feel
like they have to take on all this oness
to do something for other people and
that's not real because when it comes
down to it if you ask probably 80% of
the players that aren't in the position
they used to be in and ask them who can
do for them it's not going to be many if
any for that matter meaning people who
who are willing to help them of course
yeah and then how are they positioning
themselves to where when the ball stops
it's about just having a ton of money
like how can I do something else how can
I be perceived while playing as someone
who can transition and do something else
you know there's this idea that I made a
lot of money I don't have to do nothing
else well that's not true because you
made a lot of money but you didn't
diversify your portfolio unless your
money is making money for you and you
live a lifestyle in which your 8% or
your 10% or whatever it is return each
year is able to pay your
bills and your taxes on your home and
stuff like that then you got to go to
work you have to go to work you know and
it's a big difference when youve when
you made $50 million this year and then
next year you made nothing it's just
tough yeah what do you say to the
players when they start to take on that
onus you were mentioning right so people
come to them and ask them for things I'm
sure it happens all the time for many
different directions from people they've
met along the way from new
people when you see someone who's about
to take on too much or accept that what
do that conversation look like if they
come to me with the conversation it's
very real I don't really have a lot of
gray in me it's pretty black and white
even though I have a gray clutch
Athletics
hoodie it's pretty black and white for
me because that's how life is Right life
is There's No Gray in it man outside of
the days
300 of the days in Cleveland Ohio that's
gray but like there's no real gray in it
man and and I just I just want them to
understand how important it is
to get their ducks in a row at their
youngest age because that's when they
make their money at their youngest the
average person makes their money between
the age of 45 and 65 the average athlete
makes their money between the age of 19
and 25 maybe 30 if they get that far
yeah it's so hard
and then learning when to jump off that
that dream train right yes I know you
thought you was going to be a Hall of
Famer you thought you was going to be an
all NBA guy you thought you gonna play
15 years in the
league but if you play two or three or
five save your money do the things while
playing to learn how this business
actually operates and start to position
yourself to where I can still be around
the game in a different form when when
you look at guys there's a reason why
top coaches aren't really ex
players or ex-star players let me say
that Exar players because they wasn't
allowed to have the ego that most star
players have and so they be actually
become better coaches when you look at a
tyo when you look at a guy like Adrien
Griffin who's getting an opportunity now
in in Milwaukee welld deserved overly
deserved when you look at guys
like Quinn
Snyder who you know Quinn played ball he
was good player he you know he wasn't
John
Stockton right but but he's a hell of a
Coach and he's gonna make more money as
a coach than he would as a player tou
has already done it Darvin Ham's going
to do it when you really think about
this because I study this
stuff a guy like Jamal Mosley he tried
to play ball and play ball a little bit
but whatever
but as a coach he's going to be but he
paid his dues you know went from
development to this to that and just
have the time give yourself time and be
patient and do the little things
necessary to continue to reposition
yourself and it's going to happen for
you and that can be a part of any part
of the ecosystem of sport in any sport
for that
matter so you mentioned ego and I'd love
to focus on this for a second because it
seems like LeBron
has never been known as someone who's
ego-driven and I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this of course but as
someone that talented and that driven
obviously putting in intense
amounts uh of work and
dedication one could imagine a world in
which a person like that would be very
ego- driven and certainly they account
examples what do you think it is that
has led him to be that way or is he just
that way right out of the box I think
he's that way but
also LeBron's from akan
Ohio if you ever been to akan there's
not much there right so there wasn't
these things
that allowed him to develop
this ego per se when you think about
friends same guys he went to high school
with same guys he go back with now yeah
he's LeBron but they don't give it they
don't they still talk crazy to them and
they talk about things and they laugh
and joke or whatever and fall out and
don't you know and get back together you
know that's just the life and then when
you think about his business
infrastructure myself Maverick Randy Etc
we don't really care that he's LeBron
per se like he values our opinion we
value him if we think something if we
have a discrepancy or disagreement of
something we're not going to hold our
tongue because he's LeBron and that's
one aspect of it but that's not even
what's the most important the most
important thing in all of that though is
he's not going to look at it as if he
can
overpower or just do something for the
sake of doing it because he is LeBron
see it takes two to tangle and that has
helped him
along the way we all have disagreements
and meetings and so on so forth but one
thing about him he's ego less enough to
know when he should
listen and that's just showing people
respect and believing in them and so I
think that's helped him tremendously now
we all have egos don't get me wrong you
have to have an ego to have confidence
but you're not invested in your ego
you're not leading with the ego you know
when the ego is supposed to come out the
room and when it's not when he's at that
you know I still called this Staple
Center he has Neo he's LeBron James
that's his show that's his stage he's
there to perform and put on a great show
sometimes too great of a show if you ask
me I would like to be a little bit more
precise with things and we debate about
that as well yeah for sure I'd like to
talk about how you think about luck so
the the name of your Memoir is lucky me
MH why lucky me why lucky me look when
you think about it I grew up in my dad's
store I learned math through playing the
numbers and selling beer wine cigarettes
Etc candy I was extremely lucky to have
that environment I was extremely lucky
to have a dad who believed in me enough
to stress education and to teach me
things in which that he knew I was going
to need to be successful in life not
successful for the moment but successful
for the duration and success not
necessarily meaning from a finance
perspective but just from a Humanity
perspective extremely lucky I was
extremely lucky to go through some of
the things I went through to help shape
me and mold me to understand life's
challenges and be able to survive those
thunderstorms emotionally and things
like that to get out on the other side
and so in addition to Jay-Z lucky me
being my favorite record mhm there's a
number of things I was extremely lucky
for I was able to make it out of an
environment to where many didn't and
when I say they didn't not because
they're dead or in jail but because
mentally they just can't see past what's
in front of them and I'm extremely
blessed and lucky to be able to do so to
the point to where it's got me this
far at the same time it's a little
sarcasm to it because look I didn't have
my mom I didn't have many options my
entrepreneurial Spirit Led me down the
road of
of what some would say was detriment in
darkness at the same time I was able to
persevere through it and so there's a
number of meanings in between it or
amongst it but ultimately I felt that
was the right title it's a great title
could you say a bit more about the sort
of entrepreneurial impulse leading You
Into Darkness if I heard you correctly
could you say a bit more about that
chapter growing up we had very little
options and if you had an
entrepreneurial Spirit you only could be
that entrepreneurial that entrepreneur
through hustles you know and that hustle
could have been everything from selling
jerseys to selling drugs selling candy
to selling inner tubes from a bike or
everything was a hustle right there was
no real jobs there was no real
understanding of corporate America there
was no opportunities and there was no
examples more importantly to see someone
go to work every day get a raise get
promoted then go from being promoted get
promoted again and then become partner
and we didn't have these examples that I
have
today if we flashback because it seems
like at least based on some of the notes
I have in front of me one of the through
lines for you one of the themes is
possibly how you do one thing is how you
do everything and I wanted to ask about
the ping and ironing your jeans as a kid
is that something that you did and if so
why did you do that yeah well my sister
taught me how to iron my jeans first and
foremost and then once she taught me it
it made me feel like I was an adult at a
very young age and then I started to
decide that just the detail in it and
iring my jeans the way I did and having
the creases line up and then I perfected
that and then from there I realized that
oh I can iron really good so I started
to advertise my ability to earn and so
when I would go to my uncle's house or
somebody's house and they get dressed
and get ready to go to the bar the club
and they they can't do two things at
once so I say hey I'll iron your clothes
for you and there's going to be a charge
for that and I made money iron and
clothes no problem and I think that the
detail of it and my preciseness of it
allowed them to trust me more and the
more they trusted me the more I can
charge so now iron and jeans is one
thing but if I'm ironing silk pants or a
silk shirt and I knew how to adjust the
iron to wool and linen and so on so
forth and I built a good business I I
and I made money every which way like
that right and so me understanding that
and willing and wanting to align those
creases properly and take my time to do
it and prepare as such with the iron and
the Water and Light starch and things
like that that quote that you made
how you do one thing is how you do
everything that's at its foundation and
your approach to it right because
whatever Arena you're
in just your approach to that that
detail staying that detail oriented will
allow you to to progress so that's what
that meant you know usually I wouldn't
ask about something in the background
but I have to ask what is the polar bear
statue in the background behind you
polar bear
that's just interior design you know
okay I have a thing for polar bears
that's why I was asking yeah but that's
an Ernie Barnes behind me that picture
okay can you tell me more about the
Ernie Barnes piece you seem like
somebody who chooses things I mean I
imagine these things aren't just thrown
in your house I mean no oh no no they're
Place yeah properly but the Ernie Barnes
Ernie Barnes is a well known black
artist he's most known for the the cover
of Marvin Gay's album yeah I recognize
the style I've never seen that piece but
I recognize the sty at the end of good
times that painting is called the Sugar
Shack Eddie Murphy actually owns the
original one from my understanding and I
was fortunate enough to be able to
purchase this piece this is called The
Runway and so you know growing up I
watch Good Times a lot didn't know
anything about art saw that saw that you
know that picture the whole time and
then as I got more into art I started to
learn different artists and Ernie Barnes
was somebody I wanted to make sure I had
my
collection what is player empowerment
what does that mean player empowerment I
know that people use this a lot but it's
really player
choice I think that often times people
say as player empowerment you get
confused with like or a player can just
do whatever they want no that's not the
case I think player empowerment comes
through the lens of
education understanding that you do have
a
choice
flexibility and having a mindset that I
don't necessarily have
to play My Career or put my career on
the same track as somebody else's
because that's what the media or anybody
would around my game would expect me to
do and and the example of that is Reggie
Miller was a great player he spent his
whole time with the Indiana Pacers Dirk
nisy was a great player he spent his
whole time with the Mavericks Kobe was a
great player spend his whole time with
the Lakers but LeBron and KD are great
players they've been on several teams
that doesn't make them any lesser than a
legend or icon as those other guys that
just named but because these people get
on
these these
media platforms and and try to create
The Narrative of what's right what's
wrong and how something should go versus
how it shouldn't no everybody's career
and their journey is their Journey but I
think it's a misconception with player
empowerment because it's not like they
can write their own checks or they own
the teams so it's only so
much power within that empowerment but I
think the empowerment is for players to
give to empower other
players to do as you feel necessary
within the within the lines of of your
professional positioning and obviously
your contract but don't feel the need to
have your journey look like someone
else's yeah
self-authoring with choice and educated
Choice like you mentioned who were the
most important influences in developing
your confidence again going back to my
dad first and foremost M my brother even
to this day when I call my brother about
something he's like and I'll be talking
to him like bro you know I'm thinking
about doing this and what do you think I
I think it may work he's like bro it's
going to work I've been telling you this
since you was a kid it's going to work
like don't even worry about like this is
his exact
conversation but outside of family you
know I've had a lot of people steal
confidence in me my Uncle Warren when I
played mini football
they would put the confidence in you you
may not like the words but you know that
they're instilling the confidence in you
what kind of things might he say how did
he do that who my brother or my Uncle
Warren your uncle I played quarterback
when I was a munity league football
player and or you know if I switched to
receiver safety you know it would just
you know what you're supposed to do you
know how to do it you know we worked on
you know we practice on you can do it
mhm that was the mentality we had the
expectation
of when belich was leading the Patriots
when the Patriots were if they didn't
want go to the Super Bowl it was a
failed season like that was our mun
League team like we did not go to the
city Championship something was wrong
and so you go into practice with that
understanding and that mentality and
that expectation on
you that's that's what it was and and
then and even when I was young you know
gambling shooting dice my dad wouldn't
steal that confidence in me and look
I've had some
unbelievable come back you think the
Cavs came back from 31 you don't know
what it's like to to have a $100 and you
Downing your last dollar and you 11
years old and you got $1 left and you
turn that dollar into 200 you roar all
the way back it's like a the Redemption
Trail for sure it's a unbelievable
feeling to do that and I had plenty of
nights like that whether it was on the
basketball court or whether it was at
the dice game and you know it's just I
think about those moments all the time
those were some fun times man it really
was formative times so why do a book
there's so much involved you have
to prioritize it you have to promote it
why do a book what does it mean to you
and what do you hope it will do in terms
of impact for people who read it I think
a book brings the seriousness to it
right instead of just kind of doing a
visual I think when people really sit
down and read a book you can really dive
into its chapters and read it again and
go back and so the book form was
important the timing of it was important
just you look at the state of the world
how our youth sees the world
today to different perceptions that
people may feel
like they have
without being able to have someone hear
them and so I wanted to write a book to
where I shared my experiences I shared
my
journey but also want to let people know
that you're being heard and not only are
you being heard you can be in a
different place as long as you stay in
the moment I know it may seem dark and
gray and Bleak and challenging but you
tend to think that everyone's paying
attention to you and what you got going
on and so you get
discouraged but in reality they're not
everyone has their own problems so just
get through yours totally get through
them continue to push continue to
persevere and you can end up in a
different spot and I wanted to give kids
that example and just people in general
regardless of race regardless of gender
I just wanted to give you that example
example and it was the right time for me
because I'm at a place to where I'm I'm
honestly comfortable enough and I feel
like I've accomplished enough to allow
people in because today people want to
be rich Paul they want to be a better
version they want to do the things I do
they want to be an agent because of me
and once I got to that point I wanted to
to help them
understand who I really am and why I do
the things I do because it's very
misleading to say oh this guy became a
top agent he done $4 billion in
contracts and he didn't go to
college well there's more to it yeah
that could leave a kid like he playing
Mortal Kombat it's like just sitting
there like dizzy so I wanted to give
them an
example and understanding and paint a
picture through storytelling that they
see themselves in that same mirror and
like damn I don't have to go out here
and rob somebody I don't have to go out
here and kill somebody I don't have to
go out here and feel like I'm not being
heard he had the same problems I did wow
I see myself in that and and here's an
example
that I see every day I can see them I
can touch them whatever I'm accessible
to people I I like to talk to people
when they see me out in the street that
was encouraging for me what I didn't
want to do is write a puff piece and
that's what I said to my team I said if
I do a book it will not be a puff piece
I don't want to write a book on look
what I did look how much money I made
look how I don't need to do that that
could be the second book that can't be
the first book the first book people
need to know who I am at my core what
I've been through and it was therapeutic
for me and I'm I'm glad I did it it was
something that I'm I'm proud of and
hopefully when people read the book they
feel inspired by it and the subtitle is
great also I mean I love I love
everything about it I mean lucky me A
Memoir of changing the odds and
certainly you've demonstrated that and
just a just a few closing questions for
you the first
is if you could put anything on a
billboard this is metaphorically
speaking just to get a message out to
billions of people could be image could
be a quote could be a word could be
something that's inspired you anything
at all what might you put on that
billboard you have any ideas I would put
kindness never hurts love is never
wasted Unity starts with you trust makes
it possible Community is a mentality and
honesty keeps it real and I
think you need all those things to
change the
way people are living today for the
better you need all those things
to help uplift somebody you need all
those those things to unite and
collaborate and you need all those
things to be
clutch Rich I've really enjoyed spending
time with you people can find you on
Instagram at Rich paaul Twitter at Rich
paaul 4 the number four and certainly
they can find the new book Lucky Me A
Memoir of changing the odds everywhere
fine books are sold is there anything
else you'd like to say or anything you'd
like to ask of my audience uh anything
at all that you'd like to add before we
wind up but I want to thank you for
having me on I know you're not into
sports like that but
obviously you know I'm doing something
right to get your attention so I'm happy
for that and to the audience you don't
have to be in sports don't feel like you
know I have to be in sports to read this
book you don't even have to know how to
spell Sports per se it's just I think
that it's important to to really care
about what other people are going
through despite what Society teaches us
I think is important to really dive into
to other people's experiences because it
allows you to to try to have a better
perspective and a better understanding
of people and so I'm I'm glad to to have
matur to the point where I can honestly
say that because I grew up in an
environment where we didn't care about
nothing at
all well rich I can barely spell Sports
but I can spell human and your story is
intensely human and I think it will
resonate with a lot of
readers and it's a hero's journey of
changing the odds and I'm very excited
to see what it'll do in the world so
lucky me A Memoir of changing the odds
is the book everyone so please check it
out and thank you so much for taking the
time Rich this has been a lot of fun
thanks Tim I appreciate it and to
everybody listening we'll include links
in the show notes as usual to everything
at tim. Blog podcast until next time be
just a bit Kinder than is necessary to
others and to yourself and thanks for
tuning
in